but the situation in in south africa
as you know the numbers have been
increasing and
the governments are obviously looking at
every possible measure
to increase the intensity of the
response there in support of their
communities
and as part of that due diligence and
reaching out for
support and assistance and advice the
the
the minister of health and his director
general as well as other staff in the
ministry
have been reaching out to our regional
office in africa to
our regional director chidimuetti but
also directly
to the director general and our most
recent conference call was
a three-level conference call in which
we were discussing the challenges
that south africa has faced particularly
the operational and technical challenges
of scaling up the response at community
level
scaling up surveillance providing extra
support to laboratory diagnostics
amongst other things who
is working with south africa to provide
surge capacity in
very specific technical areas um and
we're also providing virtual support and
in fact a virtual mission as well to
support that so
a number of key individuals at global
and at regional level will be both
providing physical on-site support to
the response as well as virtual support
in the coming days
south africa has a tremendous internal
capacity in public health it has
it has done a good job in responding to
what has been an escalating situation
and it is only wise uh and uh
smart that a responsible government will
reach out for
whatever assistance it feels that it
needs to add to the quality and
intensity of its response
and oh yeah on the mission yeah well um
yes well we i'm not quite sure if
they're there yet but uh
our small team is uh hopefully on its
way
to to beijing uh or
or will be very very soon uh we've been
engaged in a series of uh
virtual consultations again with
scientific and other
colleagues at the national health
commission at the china cdc
in looking at work already done on the
preliminary or earlier investigations
and scientific
studies on the origin of the virus we
continue to look
at the opportunities for scientific
collaboration
collaboration and the terms of reference
for an international mission
and we're already beginning to reach out
to
experts at the international level
to see who will be available and most
appropriate to be able to support
an international mission in the in the
coming weeks again as i said previously
the logistics of that are not
straightforward i can assure you
but we are pleased that the the
we now see the level of engagement that
i think is important and will drive a
successful mission
these are important questions the
answers are even
more important and i think everybody in
the chinese
scientific community and the
international scientific community
is anxious to move forward with the
appropriate studies to fully understand
the animal
origins of this virus
thank you dr tedros did you want to say
anything more about south africa or no
you want me to say more okay sorry
no thank you sophie i think mike had
covered it
very well uh we had a very productive
meeting
with his excellency minister mueller
zweli mr zweli my brother
and the um you know we have been
interacting all along
this is you know
a regular contact and
we have agreed to boost our cooperation
and as mike said all levels participated
from our country office regional and
and and headquarters and we will
increase the frequency of our engagement
and based on some of the requests that
south africa has already done
so we will intensify
our cooperation and
i hope to make make progress
in controlling the pandemic thank you
thank you dr tedros the next question
comes from morocco
from monsieur and i apologize if i get
your name wrong
el buktawi from map
morocco please unmute yourself and ask
your question
uh mr el baktawi can you hear us
from morocco
it sounds like we've lost him so we'll
go
on uh we have a question from spain from
isabel from efe from the spanish news
wire isabel could you unmute yourself
and go ahead with your question
do you hear me very well
please proceed
[Applause]
hello hello it's belle we can hear you
hear anything sorry
i don't know if you are hearing
we are hearing you uh can you hear us
it sounds like we've got some technical
problems we'll send isabelle a message
to
tell how she can ask her question a
little later
we have imogen imogen fox bbc
let's hope we do better with you imogen
can you unmute yourself and ask your
question
hi margaret yet i hope that that i'm the
exception to the rule if you can hear me
well done um
i just wonder i know you have been very
quiet on this
but we had these quite uh surprising
comments from u.s secretary of state
mike pompeo in london on
tuesday um do you have any
response to that or
could you give us an idea of how how you
think a big organization like the who
can respond to that kind of comment
yeah thank you um i think we have
we haven't kept quite actually we
released the statement
and as you know the comments
were done i think on tuesday last
tuesday
and the comments are untrue and
unacceptable
and without any foundation for that
matter
and our sole focus
and the focus of the international the
entire organization
is on saving lives
if there is one thing that really
matters to us
and which should matter to the entire
international community it's saving
lives and wha will not be
distracted by these comments and
we don't want the entire the
international community also to be
this distracted as you know
one of the greatest
threats we face continues to be
the politicization of the pandemic
kobe 19 does not respect borders
ideologies
or political parties and i say i have
said it many times
coveted politics should be quarantined
and i'm appealing again to all nations
to work together politics and
partisanship have made things
worse so
what is very important is science
solutions
and solidarity but i repeat
the allegations are untrue and without
any foundation
thank you if i
if i might add i
feel the need to say something as an
american as a
proud who employee
i have had the honor and privilege to
sit next to dr tedros and
dr mike ryan for i don't know how many
days since the beginning of this
pandemic
and i have never been more proud to be
wh-o
i've worked for this organization with
this organization for more than 10 years
we have dedicated staff in all of our
regions
and in countries working all over the
world we have partners that continue to
work with us
and engage with us and i am particularly
grateful for those that continue
to show their support for us but i see
firsthand
every day the work that dr tedros does
that mike does that our teams do
all over the world we are firmly focused
on saving lives as dr tedros has said
firmly focused we will not be distracted
and that is what we remain and we will
continue to remain focused on
um and just on that
many of us have worked in seven days a
week
20 hours a day for the last seven months
uh everything we think everything we do
is focused on
trying to save lives and we send
and have sent for years our people into
harm's way every day
many of us have spent months and years
on the front line
risking our lives and worrying our
families for
for decades in this fight for social
justice
it's it's really important that we try
and maintain the morale
of all frontline workers be the who the
rest of the un
and i can say
too that's uh none of us are perfect
but we all serve we serve to save lives
and we're here in the service of the
vulnerable people of the world
and again i am proud to sit by the side
of
dr tedras in doing that because uh
our organization and his leadership are
intertwined um
and we have benefited from that
leadership from that direction
from a transformation in our
organization and i can say this
as someone who's spent a quarter of a
century associated with this
organization
transformation that i thought might
never come
for an organization that truly needed to
change the way it did business
i've seen that happen we are committed
to that
we are proud proud to be who
and we will remain so and we will serve
the vulnerable people of the
world regardless of what is said about
us thank you so much
dg and dr van kerkov and talk to dr ryan
i can only i'm not meant to say anything
but proud to be wh
now more than ever the next question
goes
to uh chen waiwa
from china daily chen could you unmute
yourself
and please go ahead hi
uh dr tedious so you just mentioned
in the opening remarks that half of the
cases
came from three countries we all know
that's us
brazil india so my question is
has whole the
special resources on these three
countries to put them on the
right trajectory because you know as dr
ryan mentioned about the coercive
measure i i sort of
find it confusing because uh like some
us congressmen
rejecting wearing marks masks they say
i have a facial autonomy so that sounds
ridiculous to me but
i don't know is this coercive if i
ask you to wear a mask thank you
um i i think
the three countries you mentioned are
powerful
able democratic countries
who have tremendous internal capacities
to deal with this disease and there are
many hundreds of thousands of brave
frontline workers doctors
nurses hygienists logisticians and
others
who fight in the front lines just like
in every other country
you know it is a given large countries
can have large problems because by their
very nature they are large
they are populous they are complex
and and and also uh
there are differences of opinion and
differences between the federal and the
state level
in many countries in all over the world
it's one of the prices that countries
pay for
for that uh for democracy in in that
context
so uh we are always ready and we'll
always remain ready
to provide advice input and service
to any of our member states wherever
they are
and constantly offer advice and support
to them
but these these particularly these three
countries and many more
have tremendous internal capacities and
i believe can turn this around
because of the nature of their public
health their science
and their their innate capacities to
fight this disease and i trust
that these three countries are doing
that and will do that
and will escalate and and upgrade the
responses in order to
to to to bring this disease under
control maria
and just add on the legal topic one of
the reasons that we've set up this new
law lab is to help countries to better
understand how they can legislate
for the response as dr ryan said it's a
matter of balance between
making sure that people voluntarily work
with us to make sure that we
save lives but in cases where
legislation is necessary
we're trying to provide countries with
good good advice about
what's what what good legislation looks
like that will help
help those countries to to deal with
things like the compulsory wearing of
masks in appropriate circumstances
and to deal with quarantine in
appropriate circumstances and that's
where the legal lab comes in
to help countries to better understand
what other countries are doing
and to share information about how they
can make appropriate laws
which follow who guidelines and help
save lives
if i could just briefly add um to say
that um
you know to supplement uh what mike has
said that you know we stand ready to
support all countries everywhere
um i think many people certainly in in
my
uh friends and family perhaps thought we
were here really to support maybe lower
income countries or lower resource
countries
but we are here to help all countries
and we work through our regional offices
and we work through our country offices
to provide support to
everyone everywhere and i think just a
message
to say that even in those three
countries that have the highest numbers
of cases right now
can be turned around it can be turned
around
and there are tools that all countries
have
that can do that it takes tremendous
will it takes tremendous leadership
and the work of all people to be part of
the solution
and to play their role and what dr
tedros was speaking about today in his
speech
and what you've heard us say many times
is everyone has a role to play
and so when you are thinking about the
steps that you need to take to present
prevent yourself
from getting infected you're not only
protecting yourself
you're protecting others that live
around you that you live with that you
socialize with
so continue to practice physical
distancing continue to clean your hands
continue to adhere to the
recommendations that are put in place
for your safety continue to know where
that virus is and learn everything you
can about this virus
because as we do every day we're
learning something every day
and some of our guidance may be adapted
some of the guidance and recommendations
in your area
may be adapted based on that current
situation so keep yourself well informed
about how you can protect yourself your
family and your community
margaret i just may add to that who's
regional office for the southeast asia
is based in delhi
under the leadership of dr putnam singh
himself is
indian and one of our largest country
officers in the world is actually
in india and works very closely with the
indian government similarly
one of our strongest officers in the
americas is in brazil
and we work with both the federal and
state level have worked together very
successfully on the management of dengue
yellow fever and other diseases so they
the
the the those countries are intertwined
with us obviously the united states is
not in need of
our assistance most of the time but
certainly the u.s and i've said this
before the u.s government is deeply
uh and its institutions particularly
scientific institutions are deeply
entwined
with global health and providing strong
scientific and public health input to so
many global health agendas
over the last 10 or 20 years so
these countries are not only important
in the cobalt response but each of them
has a tremendous contribution to make at
the global level
and it is a time when we do need global
leadership
and and large countries in regions
very often set a standard for others
they set an example
and other countries follow and people
look to india people look to brazil
people look to the united states for
leadership for examples for ways of
doing business
and they tend when those are successful
to copy those strategies
so these countries are not only
important in their own right they're
very important
as regional and global beacons of uh
of doing the right thing
thank you for those comprehensive so
we now will have we will go to pretty
neat from here in geneva geneva health
files
pretty please unmute yourself and ask
your question
hi can you hear me please yes yes very
well
yes uh yes my question um is basically
um i wanted to find out uh whether
uh who is uh concerned about
the lukewarm response uh it has received
for the kobit 19 tech pool um
is there an update that you can share we
see that not
as many countries have signed up as as
one hoped
and it is it possible to share some
details on what kind of technology you
expect to be shared and so on
thanks for taking my question
oh the costa rican initiative yes yes
i we would have to get back to you on
the details here your question is well
asked but i don't have the specific
details on the number of countries and
the technologies
that are currently on the ctap platform
so what i propose we do
is we get an information we send it
through margaret to you and maybe bring
on monday we will also maybe uh give a
couple of minutes to give an update on
ctap if that's okay with you
excellent question and just send it to
me harris m at who dot int
and we'll we'll make sure we you get a
good answer
uh the next question is for um
isabel we're going to tr isabel has
reconnected isabelle from fa so isabel
please unmute yourself
and ask your question
yes do you hear me very well
please ask your questions thank you
thank you very much for trying again
thank you my question is as you know
there are several outbreaks in spain
and most of them uh even if they are
restricted to a few geographical songs
this is happening after you warned
that we we should have been very
careful after the confinement and i
would like to hear from you what is the
lesson
we have to learn in spain and in other
countries
in this context a quite important
proportion of these contaminations
happened in nightclubs as you mentioned
do you think that is most most
reasonable
uh to close these sites
until the situation is under control
um uh i think
the the i think we have to be uh careful
here that when
we see clusters of cases or a rise in
cases after
lockdowns are lifted that in some way
that that is
projected as an er or a fault or a
failing it it happens
the minute you raise the pressure on the
virus and the virus is a community level
you will
see sporadic or clusters of cases
the question you should ask is what is
the reaction to that
what we've seen is in areas that have
lifted restrictions very early without
having control on the virus have seen
a very fast jump back up but in other
countries even in countries that have
brought the disease under
extreme control like germany and spain
and others but the numbers have been
suppressed to very low levels
that when you open up there's always a
chance that the disease can be imported
or the disease can spread from
unseen clusters and the real
i suppose test of community and
government is how quickly can you get
those under control
how quickly can you detect the cluster
how quickly can you test the people in
that cluster how quickly can you get the
results from that
how quickly can you identify the
contacts how quickly can you identify
the risk factors
was the risk factor in night club was
the risk factor a mass gathering
what do you need to do at the community
level to prevent that happening again
do you need to implement some local
movement restrictions
what we're really trying to get here is
move from
as i said before using a very big hammer
to trying to be more precise
in what we're doing instead of
restricting everyone
we try and go after the virus and we try
and identify where the virus is
and then specifically and surgically in
a sense excise the virus from the
community by
minimizing the impact on the lives and
livelihoods
of the community by focusing in on cases
on contacts and investigation
so countries coming out of lockdown even
countries with low levels of disease
will experience potential cases and
clusters of disease
and i believe in this case spain like
many other countries
have reacted uh quickly they've reacted
well um
and our uh under the the incidence of
disease
is is is is stable and yet
we still have to deal with the a few of
these clusters that have emerged
in a number of countries so um i think
and that is really how we get to what
the dg spoke about
we have to learn to live with this virus
we will not be able to eliminate or
eradicate this virus
in the foreseeable future and we have to
learn to find a way
to get back to our lives to get back to
some kind of normality
to do that with as
dave has spoken about with respect to
human rights with respect
to the use of law with using every
single tool that we have
as a society to suppress this virus in a
sustainable way
to make maximum disruption to the virus
and
minimum disruption to ourselves now how
do we go about doing that we need
everybody on board
the dg spoken it's not just the
authorities on board it's not just
the responsibility of the authorities
it's also of communities and people
within those communities
and more and more the youth and not just
the older ones the old fogies like
myself and others
youth culture can break this
youth culture can help drive this
pandemic
or youth activism can help break the
back on this virus
and going to the issue then of closing
sites
everything about gathering is related
to the background incidence of the
disease in the community
if there is no disease in the community
then it's safe to re-engage in
normal activities if disease is in the
community and if you have intense
community transmission
then any activity that brings people
together in crowds especially indoors
will lead to further transmission of the
disease because if you don't know where
the virus is
but you do know the virus is spread in
your community
and you bring people together in large
groups you're going to get transmission
and in that sense governments are going
to have to make decisions
based on the local epidemiology as to
whether things like bars and clubs in
particular circumstances need to be
closed or have restricted
numbers or whatever it is they need to
do to reduce the chance
of person-to-person transmission maria
thanks i i really appreciate the
question because i think so many people
are dealing specifically with this
question
um of what are the lessons that that can
be learned you know once you've been
successful at suppressing transmission
you know what about these sporadic cases
and clusters that are that are starting
to
um appear i think the lesson is is that
we should expect
this we should be ready for this to
happen and with all of the systems that
are in place now which countries have
worked so hard to put in place
they need to be used fast they need to
be used aggressively and robustly
and with no regrets with the exception
of ensuring
that when these interventions are put
back in place again
where you may shut down something
temporarily it's done for a
temporary amount of time and it's done
in this
the lowest or smallest geographic region
as possible
i think everyone wants to avoid these
huge so-called lockdown measures again
we do too we we hope that we don't
need to see these again but if
these outbreaks are dealt with swiftly
if the test treat contact trace care for
if all of that is put in place and done
really quickly
you have an opportunity to really put
that fire out quickly
and we are seeing countries do that i
think it's important to know where
as as mike has said where these
outbreaks are occurring
is it in a particular entertainment
sector
is it in a long-term living facility is
it in another
closed settings and if you as an
individual
have a an opportunity to avoid going to
a nightclub
maybe it's worth avoiding that nightclub
for a little while i've nev i don't
think we've talked so much about
nightclubs in
in in recent days in recent weeks
because these tend to be the hot spots
right now
but i think having a blanket of closing
all night clubs is not the solution
either
i think we need to have a data-driven
approach where is the virus
where are the opportunities for the
virus to transmit
if it happens to be in a certain area
then yes perhaps maybe they need to be
closed for a little while
but again you have a you have a choice
yourself to to make
and say do i do this do i go to this i
said the other day there's a lot of
things that people want to be doing
um i do too we all do here but there's
not necessarily things
we we need to do the things we need to
do to keep our family safe and alive and
and we need to make perhaps make some
sacrifices
ourselves so that essential workers and
frontline workers
who are putting themselves at risk every
day to keep
businesses going to serve us food
for healthcare workers who are out there
who are caring for patients they need to
go to work and they choose to go to work
proudly and we are very grateful for
that so again we all have a role to play
and we really do need to make decisions
based on risk
to keep ourselves safe and keep our
families safe
thank you very much dr van kerkov the
next question
we are going to try to go back to
morocco and and
i believe that monsieur el bakturi
has reconnected so monsieur el bakturi
please unmute yourself and ask your
question
looks like we are not we're out of luck
today
we have come up to the six o'clock we've
come up to the end of the hour
so our closest press conference but of
course i will hand it over
to the director general for final words
thank you thank you margaret thank you
to all who have
joined us today and see you on
monday in our next presser
so thank you again
you